did humans breed dogs to be friendly
compared with wolves dogs are hyper
social to go out of their way to seek
attention and affection from others
particularly humans but dogs aren't the
only ones who are predisposed towards
being friendly there does seem to be a
genetic component to sociability in
people humans with Williams Buuren
syndrome are also known to be hyper
social with affected children often
running up and hugging people at random
scientists were curious if the same
genes involved in WBS are also involved
in sociability and dogs find out
researchers tested 18 dogs and 10 wolves
for traits related to sociability with
humans in one experiment a person sat in
the middle of an enclosure well either
dogs or wolves were nearby during the
eight minutes of testing the dogs spent
53 percent of their time within close
proximity of the unfamiliar human the
wolves were loners only walking by the
unknown person 35 percent of the time it
turns out that canine chromosome 6
appears to have a section analogous to
the genes in humans that when absent
cause volumes berenson peering into the
gene data scientists saw that hyper
social dogs had more DNA disruptions in
this region than the more aloof wolves
the researchers say that while
individual experience equally important
through genetics when it comes to
sociability the finding suggests the
human question may have contributed to
the rapid domestication of dogs I'm sure
that a genetic engineering may be one
reason why your food closest to you come
home every day
[Music]
you